we have this from the post millennial
breaking full footage reveals former
Marine Daniel Penny putting Jordan Neely
in recovery position passengers
complimenting him let me just put this
in simple terms for all of you the story
of the violent homeless man who is
threatening to hurt everyone who said he
didn't care if he'd go to jail who was
subdued by three men
he died the left has called for this
former Marine's criminal prosecution and
indictment and AOC is referred to it as
a murder and as it turns out new footage
proves that this morning was actually
attempting to save the life of this man
of course I don't think AOC cares I
think she's maliciously evil and that
what these people truly want is anarcho
tyranny if you're a criminal you'll get
all of the defense in the world and if
you are the innocent civilian trying to
live your life they will beat you down
and blame you for everything
so the story here I suppose really
interesting is that um the reason this
video wasn't discovered immediately was
because it was taken by an individual
who doesn't speaks English as their
first language and so it was uploaded in
Spanish and it was then found in a
Spanish language Facebook post and then
uploaded thus debunking the whole
narrative
surprise surprise another Covington
scenario the left goes nuts calls for
blood and then the video surfaces later
proving this guy actually was trying to
save this dude there's no there was no
question about like he wasn't trying to
kill the guy he was trying to prevent
him from hurting other people and it
sucks that he died but it's not like
it's it's probably incompetence or
whatever fine but he wasn't
intentionally trying to kill the man but
he doesn't have the standard that law
enforcement would have to execute a move
like this right because he's a civilian
bystander that has no specialized
training in that now he has combative
training he was a marine he knows how to
do a choke hold but if you were going to
do this thing properly you'd probably do
what's called a carotid restraint a
blood choke right you want to get the
the blood stopping and you don't want to
stop the the breathing so he could have
done something he did an air choke it
sounds like but you could see his elbow
probably was a little bit too it needs
to be centered on there end of the day
and it doesn't matter in this video I'm
still breathing the guy was still
breathing still moving and still trying
to get up and they put him in the
recovery position I teach emergency
medicine I used to teach it even at the
uh at the FBI's Academy I've been a
paramedic for over a decade and so basic
Hands-On medicine you can do it with
almost nothing and what he did there is
textbooked Excellence for a bystander
you could save people's lives by putting
them in a place where their their their
trachea is going to be open that they
can actually get air he put them in that
left lateral recoverment position which
is what you do when people are knocked
out unconscious you can do it to drunks
there's a story from a year ago where a
homeless belligerent man
walk up to a woman who was standing on
the subway and shoved her right in front
of the trainers was coming killing her
so and there were 25 or so incidents
last year of that happening
so you get imagine you're on the train
and you keep hearing about violent
homeless people murdering people or
you've heard a couple times and you've
heard about 25 people they tried to kill
then someone gets in your train you're
trapped your Train's moving and they say
they're gonna hurt somebody and they
don't care if they go to jail three
people who live in New York thought it
would be reasonable to attempt to subdue
this man I'm not going to then put the
responsibility on the marine trying to
stop a violent criminal I mean he's been
he was arrested 40 times a kidnapped a
kid before he punched him in the face
yep accurate if he doesn't know how to
do anything other than what he did it's
not his fault I don't blame the victims
of the crime for doing whatever they can
to try and stop themselves from being
victims well exactly I mean so whenever
a senseless act of violence occurs the
left has an inexhaustible list of
excuses for the person who went out and
blatantly committed an unjustifiable act
of violence but when someone defends
themselves well now they're evil
incarnate now we're not going to examine
the situation we're not going to give
them the luxury of analyzing every
socio-economic factor that could have
led to them being in that situation
we're not going to say they did it
because there wasn't enough funding
given to their school library and they
would have been an upstanding member of
society who never did anything wrong if
the situation had been different it's
simply that person is evil incarnate and
we have to lock them up and throw away
the key now we're very tough on crime
imagine if instead of coming out and
saying why aren't they giving mental
health treatments to these these these
poor poor homeless men it's like okay
well he was violent what if they came
out and said why aren't they giving
proper self-defense training to our
Marines who could have done a proper
restraint that would not have harmed
this man oh there's a bunch of different
ways you can pretend to be outraged
that's right I'll tell you where my
outrage is it is the city is lacks on
crime and allows these people to roam
free they are struggling to maintain
their system at all we have leftists
saying that Rikers people die there that
people are unjustly held there and I'm
like your city is broken period your
policies don't work your politicians
don't work yet every time you Democrats
who run New York City screw up you
complain about some other let me let me
tell you where it comes from
all of these problems we hear about in
the culture were police brutality let's
talk about that they're in Democrat
cities you don't hear you know what give
name uh one of these stories and it is
in a democrat-run jurisdiction yep of
course almost almost entirely not all of
them but almost exclusively and they're
complaining is I just it's as
meaningless completely think about this
though there's two phases that they
screwed it up number one they're not
giving these guys enough training I'm
talking about the cops right now they're
not giving them the training which is
money so they're defunding they're
taking money out of the budgets of these
different law enforcement areas the
second thing is they're not backing
their play when you're a cop on the
street and I've talked to you know lots
of cops I spent a bunch of time dealing
with them in my old job they're out
there and they know they are not being
supported by the apparatus there so if
they have to use deadly force if they
have to use any justifiable Force
they're probably going to be facing
charges and there's no joy like they're
not going to be qualified immunity
they're not going to be scoped they're
not going to have defense that's paid
for by the local jurisdiction it's going
to come out of their pocket or it's
going to come out of the Union they're
going to get crushed so they are they do
the Freddie what do they call the
Ferguson effect the Freddie gray effect
they scale back and they let this thing
happen and that's how you get a crazy
man threatening to kill people on a
subway when somebody saw him there's two
he went by cops this is what community
policing looks like right when the
community is doing the policing that's
what you get you get P because and I
said that on Twitter the other day and
and some leftist get got all up in my
mentions and had a problem and it's like
oh there's all these books and that's
not how it works and Etc but what
they're neglecting to address is that
when you say community policing on the
internet to the vast majority of the
population you're going to have a
significant portion of unsophisticated
people that are going to hear that and
they're going to think I have to take
care of myself it's my job to help now
whether or not that's the case it
doesn't matter people are going to think
that and they're going to act like that
and that's what you get that's that's
all that you get you're going to get
more of this the fewer cops you have the
fewer security or the less security you
have on the subway system the more
you're gonna get this so this is this is
100 aoc's fault this is Rashida talib's
fault this is a
Ayanna Presley's fault the squad they're
all guilty all of the Democrats that
have been screaming
there the mayor well no the mayor's
actually kind of good I think he was
complaining but it's the DA's fault it's
it's the vice president's fault for
bailing out people when they were
rioting in 2020. it is 100 the Democrats
fault down the line they were calling
for this the blood is on their hands and
for them to even try to blame the poor
guy that was trying to help the poor
people on the subway is absolutely
absurd and should not even be tolerated
by by reasonable people so uh
who here thinks this guy is going to be
indicted and convicted
I I say yes I think they're going to
criminally indict him and then they're
going to convict him and they're going
to get him on some charge where they're
like we understand that there was some
fear here but he went too far and just
because you're scared does not give you
the right to kill so you know there's on
the side or something yeah there's a
reasonableness standard they can indict
him that's going to be that's a
no-brainer okay so we can just throw
that that's gonna happen for sure
there's demand for it so there will be a
supply for it they will make that happen
but what you do have is a lot of people
that ride the subway that can make on a
jury there's a lot of people who have
seen that situation and the question is
this are they going to believe their own
Lying Eyes and what they've seen and
experience and the fear that they've
maybe had and the internet videos
they've shared with their friends or are
they going to go with what their party
tells them they're supposed to do
because New York City is not universally
it's like 70 they're going to go with
what their party tells them to do you
know why because they're gone you only
need one juror they're going to be
escorted into the courthouse by armed
police with rifles as violent Riders
scream about and scream threats at them
and then go to their homes and uh what
was it one uh what trial wasn't where
one of the witnesses or whatever had a
pig's head put on their porch and a
blood splattered on it but it was like
the wrong house or something like that I
don't know in Minnesota yeah I was the
one in Minnesota like the showman trial
in Minnesota you have armed police with
rifles long guns standing outside
escorting in the jury looking at all of
the chaos and violence the message is
clear it doesn't matter what you think
is right the far left is firebombing
buildings and they will come after you
so if this guy gets indicted I really
don't see someone in New York being like
I will accept the consequences in a city
surrounded by far left extremists
what if they were able to get the venue
outside they won't do it
look at look at Minnesota when they so
they can appeal I mean they can make
that request and the judge it'll get
denied they'll say uh there's what
happened in Minnesota they said there's
no jurisdiction In Minnesota where
people don't know what happened
now my response that is then case
dismissed because the Constitution
warrants a fair trial and if you're
saying outright everyone is biased then
you cannot try this man sorry he's free
to go they didn't do that they just said
no you're gonna buy his trial and we're
gonna lock you up sorry have a nice day
I I just look there's a possibility this
guy I I hope and the other piece is it
has to be up in front and center that
this guy what he did was was appropriate
and and you know using your voice the
way you're doing it is actually really
important because otherwise this guy
gets steamrolled he has no chance I do
agree with you that there's a very high
probability the other thing is Phil what
you were saying earlier you know
community policing and the nature of it
the Supreme Court has already ruled on
that by the way they've said that the
police do not owe you personally a duty
to safety so they have no duty to act on
your behalf they owe the public a duty
but that's a very nebulous concept it's
vague and it's open so individually you
can be screwed yeah so you may have to
defend yourself and uh I know you guys
had Mike Glover on here before he says
something be your own first responder
that's something I think is an
incredibly important message right now
and we're living in it in some places
you can do that and you'll be able to
survive you do it in New York City
you're probably going to go to jail
unfortunately even if it was correct
carry a gun
if you legally that's not a New York
yeah that's what I do but I mean I like
you know where where are legally allowed
which leads us to a the larger question
of or the larger statement the better
piece of advice live in constitutional
carry states yes because if you're in
New York I mean look at this
three people on this train thought what
this guy was doing warranted restraint
three people so if you come to me and
say what made you think it was
reasonable oh I don't but three people
did right three people had this guy down
you can't defend yourself in these
places no and look you know I I
mentioned this about New Jersey
I was told that if I was in New Jersey
in my own home and someone broke in with
the intent to kill and I shot them
they said yes you have a right to defend
yourself you'll be arrested charged with
murder you will spend time in prison you
know awaiting or or jail depending on
how just handles it and then you can
assert your affirmative defense to the
judge that it was self-defense that's
New Jersey
does is New Jersey duty to retreat
within your own home yes yeah oh my God
they call it partial castle doctrine
you're only you're only allowed to use
Force to defend your home if you have no
way out the but they they also say so I
asked them I said a window is a way out
and they gave me the gulag archipelago
response of just run away if someone's
like if your wife and children are on
the second floor you have a duty to run
out the first floor and leave them there
they expect you to leave so I was told
yes wow but it does really depend on the
judge you get there look they're
seriously that that's even up to a judge
right is insane the complete moral
insane I mean but it's not to judge
everywhere and uh even in West Virginia
there's like some reasonableness
standard to whether or not if somebody's
walking on your property you can't get
kill them you know what I mean if
someone's running towards your home
screaming with bloody rage holding a
weapon yep I'm pretty sure in West
Virginia you can West Virginia's got
some of them so West Virginia I'm pretty
sure you can defend your physical
property like your fields and this has a
lot to do with the fact that it's a
rural country with a lot of acreage and
people Farm whereas in Maryland you can
defend your house only after going
inside of it and the idea is you might
be out with your family in the field
doing work when someone threatens you
and you can use Force to defend yourself
in Maryland property tends to be a lot
smaller so they say if you're outside
your home and someone is threatening you
you have a duty to go into your home if
you are in your home and they attempt to
to break into your home I believe West
Virginia I'm sorry I believe Maryland
allows these of lethal Force to prevent
someone from breaking into your home and
then in New Jersey
you better jump out that window and go
run Buck Naked through the woods you got
to do what they call the dynamic plf
going out the window the parachute
Landing following keep your feet and
knees together and try to make it decide
I said where do I go where do I go to my
house yeah and and and the response the
cops were like kind of based they were
like no we get it but what they'll tell
you is that you that proves You're a
murderer because you're what you're
basically saying is you you had a choice
to make between standing outside or
killing a person and you made the choice
to kill a person that is not reasonable
that's that's their view in New Jersey
well and the rest of America looks at it
and says uh you know oh you do you value
your stuff more than you value somebody
else's life it's like well they value my
stuff more than they value their own
lives obviously they came into my house
that's how it works in Texas
um when I was actually going through so
before I was a a law enforcement officer
I was a concealed carrier I carried like
everybody else and I had a permit
because Texas is very newly uh come into
this sort of constitutional carry game
and when I went through those courses
one of the things that was kind of
interesting is the guy said not only can
you defend yourself in almost any
situation that you're in you have no
duty to retreat but there is actually a
deadly force scenario where someone is
stealing your stuff in Aid of nighttime
mischief and that was the way the code
was written now this goes back to maybe
2013 or 2014. so I don't know if it's
still still stands in Texas but
legitimately if someone stole your car
stereo and was running down the street
you theoretically although I don't
recommend it could shoot them in the
back in Texas I'm pretty sure you don't
want to do that in Austin but if you did
it in like Odessa you might be okay kind
of thing like you don't want to do it in
big cities but I'm just saying like
theoretically that was on underneath the
the actual statutory law that was a
defense sure once again I don't care if
you steal my car stereo I'm not going to
shoot you in the back that seems
ridiculous to me yeah but if you present
an imminent danger of death or serious
physical injury while you are doing
something like that which they call
nighttime Mischief which could just be
sneaking around your property then your
standard is actually you meet the
standard and so there are reasons to use
deadly force in that or even I just I
Googled it real quick and apparently the
answer is simply put yes you can but it
says it's not it's uh this this lawyer
says it's not been used effectively in
practice that checks because most people
are going to be like are you nuts well
there's a there's a standard of it too
right like that's the other thing you
find about people that carry concealed
weapons and all of you out there that do
that sort of thing know it as well
there's a standard of is it a judicious
use of your Force do you really want to
to go through whatever that experience
is because you're probably going to get
arrested if you shoot somebody in the
back running with your stereo I mean you
know if you are right yeah I mean you
know this but for for the listeners out
there the things that you need to
legitimize not legalize but to
legitimize because jurisdictions change
but you need to have uh ability
opportunity and intent right to to
someone has to have the ability to harm
you they have to have the opportunity
and they have to have the intent they
have to make it clear to you that
they're going to they have to be in the
same room and they have to have some way
to do it something that is reasonable is
too because there's some of those things
you can't actually you can you can't
look at somebody in the dark and know
what's coming on sure I would assume
that if you come into my house at 3am
and I'm sleeping and there's a
flashlight and well and you have hands
which you do because you opened up my
door yeah then you have some negative
intent because people sleep in their
houses at three amps yeah but then
you're expecting something the point
that I'm making is just those three
things have to actually all happen for
it to be a legitimate use of force to
defend your life thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time